you obviously reuniting with mustard on
on the first track on this one uh what
is it about
you and mustard's chemistry you think
that just makes everything so special
every time y'all link on on a i just
feel like you guys
are batting a thousand percent man
always yeah no i didn't i just feel like
we is more so big like everything is big
it's deeper than rap more so with me and
him it's just more so we got so many
songs it's just time to just
give them out at this point like we got
to just go ahead and just
do what we need to do because i just
feel like the west is like we got to
just give them what they want we gotta
we gotta be the ones that they spinning
and we gotta stay on their neck more
would you and mustard ever do a full
collab project is that i know i'm
familiar with a thousand percent is that
something you guys like seriously
consider doing a thousand percent
how many records that we haven't heard
are just honestly just a lot a lot it's
more to count it's more than you can
count more so we got ideas
songs with other [ __ ] we got our own
[ __ ] like we just we just vibe like it's
far past like all right we're going to
do a project bro we go you know it's
just like we just more so
homies brothers like more on that type
of time so it's like whenever we in
whatever city we go keep loading beats
i'm rapping on them shits it ain't no
like
expectation from it i feel like that's
why we get the best results because it's
not no
pressure would it come to us have you
thought of um because i think like you
also are getting these get in this bag
where
um
you kind of get on your r b [ __ ] i'm
thinking of the high fashions the late
at nights you know what i'm saying like
we're [ __ ] for the ladies have you ever
thought about
putting out like a
a little pack of a bunch of those
it could come you feel me it's just all
of how i feel i feel like that's just a
portion of who i am when it comes to
that type of music you know i'm you know
i'm cool with a lot of i have a lot of
female friends
cool with and you know that's just a
part of my life like gotta cater to them
and a lot of the times
the [ __ ] is gonna listen to what the
females is listening to for sure so it's
like [ __ ] i just
sometimes i like to cater to them and i
like to make songs for them